it was really disruptive selma Blair  opened up to the ladies of the talk on  Wednesday about her mid flight breakdown  in June that led to the actress being  removed from a plane for her behavior  and I don't drink anymore but I did I  was going through something I had a  glass of wine someone gave me a pill  that I thought was something I had taken  before which I don't take on a regular  basis it was something completely  different a very bad choice and I had a  total psychotic blackout Selma says she  learned a valuable lesson from the  embarrassing in-flight outburst that she  applies to her life daily totally own it  will not happen again it's really and I  keep it alive in me every day I forgive  myself but I keep it alive like this is  things can go really wrong and  humiliating and I'm so someone at a  party the other day said oh can I get  you a glass of champagne I said no no  I'm good and she said no really just one  glass just drink with me I was like  Google me  you